if the angles A, B, and C of a triangle
are in an arithmetic progression
and if a, b and c - lower case a, b and c
denote the length of the sides opposite to
the capital, the angles A - capital A, capital
B and capital C respectively
then what is the value of this expression
right over here so let's see if we can
work our way
through this, so let's just draw the triangle so
we have visualization of what all the letters
represent
so we have the angles A, B and C
so let me just draw them like this
so we have the angles A
B
and C and then the sides opposites them are the
lower case versions, so the side opposite the
capital A is lower case a
the side opposite to capital B is lower case
b and the side opposite to the angle capital
C is
lower case c. Now the first piece of information
they tell us is that they
the angles
capital A, capital B and capital C of the
triangle
are in an
arithmetic progression
arithmetic
progression
very fancy word
but all an arithmetic progression is, is a series of numbers
that are separated by the same amount, so
and let me give you some examples, so 1,2,3 - that's an arithmetic progression
2, 4, 6
arithmetic progression were separated by 2
every time
i could do 10, 20, 30
also an arithmetic progression. These are all
arithmetic progressions. So all they're saying
is
is to go from angle A to angle B - however much
that is, is this the same amount to go from angle
B to angle C. So let's see
what that tells us
what that tells us about or maybe tells us, maybe doesn't tell us anything about those angles
so if we could say
we could say we have angle A
and then we have the notion angle B
so we could say that B is equal to A plus
some constant we don't know what that is. it could go by 1, it could go by 2, it could go by 10
we don't know what it is, so A plus N
and then C
would be equal to B plus N
which is the same thing
which is the same thing as B is A plus N, so this is A plus N
it plus
plus N which is equal to
A plus
2N
so what does that tell us? Well, the other thing
we know about three angles in a triangle
that they have to add up to a 180
degrees. So:
this, this and this have to add up to a 180 degrees
let's try it out so we have
A plus A plus N
plus A plus 2N, plus A plus 2N is going to be equal to 180 degrees
we have one, two, three "A"s here, so we get 3A
plus with one N and another two N: three A plus 3 N
is equal to 180 degrees
or you could divide both sides by 3 and you
get A
plus N is equal to
A plus N is equal to 60 degrees
so what does that
what does that tell us
well A could still be anything cause if N is 1 then A is 59
if N is 10
then A is going to be 50, so it doesn't give us much information
about the angle A
but if you look up here, do you see A+N anywhere?
you see it right over here. B is equal to
A plus N and we just figured out that
A plus N has to be equal to sixty degrees
so using this first piece of information we
are able to come up with something pretty
tangible
B must be equal to sixty degrees and you
could try it out with a bunch of numbers these
could be
and 61
that's an arithmetic progression
and once again B is the middle one
right over here. These could be 50
and 70
could be 40
and 80
but no matter what the arithmetic progression
is in order for these three angles to add
up to 180 the middle one
has to be equal to
has to be equal to 60 degrees. So that was
a pretty
that's.. we're doing pretty well so far so let's
see what we can do at the next part
with the next part of problem. I'm trying to save some screen real estate right over here
okay
so they want us to figure out the value of
the expression a over c sine of two
C - capital C, plus c over a sine of two A. So
let me just write it down
so we have
i'll do it.. i'll do it in blue
a over c
sine
of two times capital C
plus c over a
sine
of two times capital A
what's that going to be equal to? so, whenever
you see stuff like this you got a 2 here
a 2 here
frankly the best things you should do is just experiment
with your trigonometric identities and see
if anything pops out of you that might be
useful
and a little bit of a clue here the first
part of the problem helped us figure out what
B is
it helped us figure out what B is
but right now the expression has no B in it.
So right now this information seems kind of
useless
but if we could
put this somehow in terms of B
then we'll have will will be making progress
as we know information about angle B
so let's see what we can do
so the first thing
i would use is
well sine of 2A - let me just rewrite each
of these
so sine of
i just say sine of two times anything
that's just the same thing as
and this is called the double angle formula
so this is
i might be wrong i was for the actual
names of them but sine of two time something
is two
sine
of that something
times the cosine of that
times the cosine of that something and you'll
see that in any trigonometric book on the
inside cover even a lot of calculus books
let's do that for this the same thing right
over here so sine of 2A over here is going
to be
2 sine of
A
cosine of A
that's just a standard trigonometric identity
and we, in the trigonometric, less we prove
that identity i think we do it multiple times
then out on front we have our coefficients till we have a over c times this
plus c over a times this
now is there anything we can do and remember
in the back of our mind we should be thinking
of how can we use this information that be is
equal to sixty
so if we can somehow put this
in the form
got a b here
when i think about how do you get a b here
I think well
you know we have a triangle here so the things
that relate the sides of the triangle when
especially when it's not a right triangle we are really gonna deal with the law of sines or law of cosines
and a law of sines let me just rewrite it over
here just for our reference
Law of sines would say sine of A
over a is equal to sine
of B over b which is equal to sine
of C
over c
And it looks like we might be able to use that
let me just read the law of cosine here
the law of cosine is c squared
it should look as a Pythagorean theorem with little
adjustment for the fact that is not a right triangle
So c squared is equal to a squared plus b
squared
minus
2 ab
cosine
cosine of C of capital C so it's law of sines and law of cosines, so let's if we can
somehow use both of these to put these in
terms of b which we have information about
well the first thing is
i could rewrite this so this is sine of C
over c and this is sine of A over a, so let
me do that
so i have
so i have the 2a
I have 2a
cosine of c let me write that separately
so that's 2a
cosine
cosine of
capital c
and then times
sine of C over c
times
with white sine
of c
that's a capital c
sine of capital c over lower case c, that's
that term and that term right over there
and then to that I'm adding
to that I'm adding let me do this the same thing over
here, I have two times
I'm going to separate
these guys out
Actually I wanted to do the sines so let me separate
I'm gonna separate this guy and in this guy out
and so I get plus
2c
cosine
of A
times sine of capital a over lower case a
times sine
of capital a over lower case a and what does this
do for me
Well look at the law of sines
right over there I have sine of C over c
that's that over there
and then I've sine of A over a and that's that over
there capital a over lower case a.
they're both equal to sign of B over b so we're making progress
we started introducing b into the equation
and that's what we actually have information about
so this
It could be rewritten a sine of be over b
so this is the same thing as sine
of capital b over lower case b
and this is the same thing a sine
of capital b over
lower case b and they're both
being multiplied
or both of these terms are multiplying
are being multiplied by that
2a cosine of capital c times that
and then plus
2c
it's a lower case c
cosine of capital a times that
so we can factor out the sine of B over b so let's do that, let's factor it out
so this is the same thing
as
it's the same thing as
2a
and I really have a sense of what the next
step is so I'll leave a space here
2a times cosine of C
plus this and these are being multiplied I'll have
some space there
plus 2c two lower case c
times the cosine of A
and all of this
all of this times
the sine
the sine of B over b and we already know that B is 60 degrees
so we can evaluate this
uh... pat
pretty easily but let's just continue
let's see if we can somehow put this
right over here in terms of b
well if you look over here we have 2a cosine of C
2c cosine of A
it's trying to look
pretty darn close
each of these terms look preety darn close to this part
to this part of the law of cosines over there and actually let's solve
for that part of the law of cosines
let's see what we could do
so if you add if you add
2ab cosine C to both sides you get 2ab
cosine of capital c
plus c squared is equal to a squared
plus b squared
or if you subtract c squared from both sides you get
2ab
cosine of capital c
is equal to a squared plus b squared
minus
c squared
and this is interesting and you know we can switch around the letters later on
but this looks pretty darn close to the so what if and this looks pretty darn close
to this except here we're dealing with
an a instead of the c, we've just switched
letters around
and we could rewrite this
actually let me rewrite it just for fun
i could rewrite this over here as
2cb
not rewrite I can swap the letters
times the cosine of A
you see I'm swaping the a(s) and the c(s) is equal to c squared plus b squared minus
a squared
there's nothing unique about the sides I can do this with all of the sides
so here
It's a big c here, you have an a and b out front
and then you have tha a squared plus b squared minus the small c squared, if you have the big A then you gonna have
the cb in the front and you're subtracting the a squared right over here
and this is useful because
this term right over here this term right
over here looks almost like this term over
here if we could just
multiply this by b
so let's do that we can multiply that by b
but let's multiply
this whole numerator this whole term by b(s)
if we multiply this whole term by b what do we get
we get a b there
we get
a b there
and of course you can just arbitrarily multiply an expression by b that'll change its value.
so what we could do is multiply the expression by b which we just did
we distributed the b across here but they were also divided by b
where which so I'll divide by b, that's an equivalent
of multiplying the denominator
the denominator there not b squared
that's equivalent of multiplying the denominator there by b. That simple thing is dividing it by b
We've multiplied it by b divided by b
That's the same thing
I'm just turning this into b squared
now what does this give us
well we have this term right over here
this term right over here is now the exact
same thing is that over there
so it is now in a squared plus b squared
minus c squared
and then this term
right over here
is now the exact same thing as this thing over here which is the same thing as that
We're using the law of
cosines so this is plus
c squared plus b squared minus
a squared
and then all of that times this sine of b
sine of capital b over b squared
now what does this give us the we have an a squared and a negative a squared things are starting
to simplify
a squared negative a squared
we have a negative c squared and a positive c squared
so what are we left with we're just left out with the 2b squared so our whole expression
has simplified to
2b squared sine of B
sine of capital b
over
lower case b squared
these cancel out
so our whole expression simplifies to
2 sine of B
and from from the get go we knew what b was we know it's sixty degrees so this is
equal to two times
the sine of sixty degrees and if you
don't have the sine of sixty degrees memorized
you can always just break out of thirty sixty
ninety triangle
so let me draw
this is a right triangle right over here this is
sixty degrees
hypotenuse has length one we're dealing with
the unit circle
this side is thirty degrees
the side opposite to the thirty degrees is one-half
the side opposite to the sixty degrees is square root of three times that so it's a sqaure root of three over two
You can even use the Pythagorean theorem to figure out
when you know one of them you could figure out the other one
So it's the sine of, sinus
opposite over hypotenuse so square root of three
over two over one
Or just square root of three over two, so this is equal to two
times
there's a home stretch, it;s very exciting !
square root of three over two
these cancel out so we are left with
the square root
of three
that's a pretty neat problem and just in case you're curious this came from the
two thousand ten IIT joint entrance examination
hard to get into engineering and
science universities in India
and they gave this example like you know hundreds of thousands of kids and you know the top
the top i don't know like two thousand actually get into one of the ideas but anyway I just thought
it was a pretty pretty neat problem